lors du forum de saint-pétersbourg nous
organiser une rencontre avec les
représentants de la communauté
d'affaires et d'investissement
international est le thème principal de
la discussion d'aujourd'hui est
évidemment consacrée aux défis majeurs
auxquels elle a été confrontée
l'humanité c'était la pandémie de
coronavirus par conséquent nous avons
proposé un format de réunion spéciale
avec des représentants des milieux
d'affaires et notamment du secteur
pharmaceutique et du centre
d'investissements directs de russie avec
le laboratoire gamme allie aussi qui a
conçu le spoutnik v et aussi avec des
représentants de pays étrangers
notamment d'argentine qui vont lancer la
production du spoutnik vais et je pense
que la composition particulièrement
représentative de cette réunion nous
permettra de coordonner notre travail de
façon efficace
or ici la vaccination revêt une
importance particulière parce qu'il est
particulièrement important de pouvoir
produire des vaccins accessibles en prix
et qui soit sûre au point de la sécurité
sur le point de vue de la qualité de
façon à ce que la population puisse être
protégé et en même temps que l'économie
puisse reprendre aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée plénière du forum
nous avons parlé du fait que l'économie
russe malgré des difficultés a su
résister aux chocs et en 2020
le pib de la russie s'est réduit un peu
moins que dans les autres pays et
aujourd'hui on devrait avoir une
progression de 40%
donc cela nous permet de travailler sur
le modèle des années
précédente dans l'agriculture dans le
secteur social dans la science dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique
je souligne que le travail de notre
personnel médical et scientifique a reçu
une aide substantielle de la part du
centre russe des investissements directs
et donc il ya eu tout un système de
diagnostic et de test des vaccins qui a
été mise en place
notre fonds souverains également
proposer un moyen de diffusion de notre
vaccin à l'étranger il est aujourd'hui
enregistrés dans 66 pays et donc
accessible à 3 milliards de personnes
nous avons dû passer donc franchir des
étapes particulièrement difficile
notamment depuis une certaine méfiance
au départ et des représentants de la
communauté scientifique mondiale
je tiens à souligner que quand il s'agit
de préserver la vie des gens leur santé
il faut mettre de côté les
préoccupations politiques les
divergences politiques et donc les
activités les agissements de certains de
nos partenaires qui cherchent
ouvertement à bloquer l'utilisation du
vaccin russe est particulièrement
critiquable les âges a montré que ça son
efficacité est un des plus élevés avec
97 5 % d'efficacité et je le rappelle la
lutte contre le chron à virus ne peut se
faire que si les efforts sont unis au
niveau mondial et nous sommes tout à
fait ouverts à la coopération avec tous
les pays qui sont procurés par cette
volonté de lutter contre la pandémie
il ya une étape importante comme je l'aï
déjà dit à l'ats l'assemblée plénière du
forum c'est le fait que les étrangers
puissent venir se faire vacciner ici en
russie facilement et en même temps
augmenter la production du vaccin
je sais que le fonds russe
d'investissements directs a lancé la
production de ce vaccin dans plus de 10
pays dans le monde ce qui devrait
suffire à proposer le vaccin à des
centaines de millions de personnes et le
travail et les travaux sur la le
développement de ce vaccin se
poursuivent et les technologies ont
permis de rendre ce vaccin d'en faire un
produit largement je tiens à remercier
les représentants des sociétés
pharmaceutiques qui ont participé à la
réunion d'aujourd'hui et je remercie
particulièrement le centre gamaleya et
le centre russe d inflation des
investissements directs
tout cela apportera une contribution
majeure dans le monde dans la lutte
contre la pandémie et cela est aussi un
bon pour les
industrie pharmacie à cet égard je
voudrais noter un certain nombre de
résultats significatifs tout d'abord il
s'agit des investissements dans les
technologies de pointe dans des projets
d'intelligence artificielle et dans la
numérisation et dans un certain nombre
d'algorithmes mathématiques et qui était
d'ailleurs le premier projet
d'investissements directs russo chinois
le centre d'investissement direct a
aussi travaillé dans le domaine des
infrastructures de transport dans
l'industrie verte et l'année dernière
nous avons investi 370 milliards de
roubles ce qui était important pour
cette année difficile pour le monde et
je vous propose maintenant d'étudier des
projets en particulier et de s'arrêter
notamment sur le renforcement et la
diffusion
l'expansion de la production de vaccins
je veux laisser la parole à monsieur qui
le mitraillent f qui est directeur du
centre russe d'investissements directs
et qui est traditionnellement modérateur
de ce type de rencontre la participation
à nos réunions
la session d'aujourd'hui a réuni plus de
30 investisseurs qui dirige les capitaux
qui dépasse 15 mille milliards de
dollars
nous avons également invité les
représentants de 25 à ce site et
pharmaceutiques de plusieurs de
plusieurs pays qui fabriquent déjà le
vaccin soutenu qu ou envisagent de le
fabriquer nous avons créé à votre
demande monsieur poutine un réseau de
fabricants du vaccin spoutnik mais cette
année c'est le dixième anniversaire du
fonds russe d'investissements directs
nous avons créé un des centres les plus
efficaces dans le monde qui a investi
dans plus de 90 sociétés des secteurs
différents tels que les infrastructures
la production industrielle lavaud
technologie terrain nous avons investi
plus de 2000 milliards de roubles dans
l'économie russe dont la plupart sont
les ressources de du fonds les
investissements avec la participation du
fonds sont de 90 % sur le marché des
investissements directs en russie et
dépasse 60% des investissements
gerald et monsieur poutine a mentionné
que en 2020 nous avons eu des
investissements considérables à dans des
sociétés vertes telles que photos dans
les éoliennes nous avons aussi
construire la plus grande centrale
solaire
nos sociétés sont très efficaces dans la
construction des routes
par exemple la société docks this a
augmenté de 10 fois nous avons annoncé
sans que nouveaux projets
d'investissement dans le cadre de ce
forum
nous allons poursuivre de d'investir
dans l'économie russe est également nous
allons investir dans notre fonds comment
avec l'union russe des industriels
l'entrepreneur pour investir davantage
dans les technologies en russie
notamment avec la participation de nos
partenaires ainsi nous continuer à jouer
un rôle important dans ces percées
d'investissement dans ce cycle qui
signifie que nous créons de nouveaux
emplois et de nouvelles sociétés des
investisseurs quoirin économie russe par
exemple avec la fondation aux pédales à
nous avons réalisé sur 106
investissements et on voit que des
milles 2 milliards de dollars ont été
lancés dans l'économie ce qui provoque
une nouvelle inflation est dans ces
conditions on fait davantage confiance à
l'économie russe et quant à la lutte
contre le coc vide nous avons beaucoup
investi dans le test de dépistage et
dans le médicament et quant au vaccin
smoothie cuvée il y à toi moments clés
tout d'abord il ya ce vaccin a été
utilisé un an d'un gennetines dans
d'autres pays et cela montre que notre
vaccin est le plus efficace et le plus
sécurisé nous avons également mené des
essais cliniques à nantes deux émirats
arabes unis et grâce à ses résultats
maintenant notre vaccin est le deuxième
faction du monde par le nombre de pics
enregistrés le vaccin même dans les pays
où on fait face à une campagne de
désinformation par exemple en allemagne
à plus de 60 % d'allemands sont prêts à
se faire vacciner par leur accent
spoutnik fait d'après les sondages
nous avons également mis au pouvoir le
vox ans rooney clyde on l'avait quittée
dépasse 70% et il y a le jour nous avons
reçu les données de leurs racines
l'efficacité parmi les passagers dépasse
80% à 6 permettez monsieur poutine à
nous voudrions vous montrer une courte
vidéo
et puis donna la parole à nos collègues
serbe qui lance la production de
spoutnik ensemble et leur action pour
l'ensemble de l'humanité dans
l'efficacité de passes 97%
le vaccin est accessible et
transportable est sûre avec le soutien
du fonds russe d'investissements directs
il a été a enregistré dans plus de 65%
du monde entier dont la population
dépasse 3 milliards de personnes
le vaccin est en train d'être approuvées
dans 15 pays du monde le président
poutine a proposé à d'autres pays à
coproduire le ac100 spoutnik les
désaccords avec plus de 20 entreprises
ont été signés dans plus de 13 filles
parmi les partenaires sont hétéros dire
que le groupe panacea biotec stellistes
biopharma klein pharma et la société
vaut crack en chine parmi le partenaire
son voile en biologie quelle bactérie
depuis pharma jean selles biotech ainsi
que shenzhen
eugene genetec en corée du sud est le
vaccin fabriqué par la société the axis
parmi les partenaires à 9 heures et que
l'acte hinson laboratoire et à 6 min
dans l'union européenne vaccin sera
fabriquée en allemagne par ra farm en
italie à par plusieurs entreprises 1
serbie par l'institut de tatort lac un
autre partenaire en arabie saoudite et
la société à radio le vaccin est
fabriqué par des sociétés turques
iranienne au kazakhstan le vaccin est
fabriqué nous également tout comme un
violeur russie et tous nos partenaires
sont unis par la volonté de combattre un
devant quand le co lead
ces entreprises pourront produire le
vaccin pour faut vacciner plus de 800
millions de personnes par an monsieur
bout de tous ces partenariats ont été
lancés à votre initiative et là je
voudrais laisser la parole à alexandre
la voûte chute du président serbe
[Musique]
bonsoir monsieur le président chers la
dure poutine ch
chers amis je tiens à saluer le travail
formidable effectuée par le président
poutine est ici en serbie nous voyons
aujourd'hui les résultats de ses efforts
il ya eu la mise en place de
technologies et on a aujourd'hui un
contrat un conte résultats concrets qui
se manifeste ici
donc merci à monsieur poutine et à
l'ensemble du peuple russe d'avoir
permis à la serbie de participer à cette
lutte de façon sélective et on a
aujourd'hui le témoignage d'une relation
forte entre nos deux pays et que nos
peuples soutiennent dans le cadre de ce
forum international international
nous avons l'occasion d'exprimer ce
soutien qui nous est exprimée de qu'ils
aient manifesté entre nos deux pays et
donc je suis heureux de voir que la
république de serbie lance la production
du vaccin
spoutnik v on a vu que le sporting est
aussi efficace et sûr que la légendaire
kalachnikov ak47 aujourd'hui de du pays
frère qu'est la russie
nous voyons une aide en armes contre ce
qu vide
donc une production une ligne de
production va être installé ici et je
salue le fonds russe d'investissements
directs pour cette coopération qui a été
rapide et efficace
vive l'amitié russo serbe et tous mes
meilleurs voeux et félicitations je cède
la parole à monsieur le directeur du
site de production en serbie mais c'est
le président de la fédération de russie
le président de la république monsieur
la serbie a été parmi les premiers pays
européens qui a commencé à utiliser le
vaccin ce pique nique mais pour la
vaccination
grâce à l'utilisation du vaccin spoutnik
v son efficacité élevée de 97,6 % la
serbie a sauvé la santé la vie nombreux
citoyens
aujourd'hui la serbie a permis le leader
européen par le nombre des personnes
vaccinées plus de 30% de la population
serbe et vacciner ceux qui deux fois
plus élevé que le nombre de personnes
vaccinées moyens
la coopération entre l'institut tornac
et le fonds russe d'investissements
directs est un exemple de coopération
réussie entre nos deux pays a mis 1 face
à une crise nous sommes reconnaissants
aux gouvernements russe et aux autorités
du fonds russe d'investissements directs
pour le soutien ou à l'instituteur lac
et à la serbie
je tiens à souligner leur rôle des
présidents de nos pieds alexandre
boudchich vladimir poutine grâce auquel
la serbie devient le premier pays
européen à fabriquer le vaccin foot nick
v sur son territoire monsieur le
président permettez moi d'appuyer sur le
bouton bouton et lancer la fabrication
du vaccin spoutnik vais en serbie
[Musique]
nous proposons deux cd maintenant la
parole à nos collègues d'argentine pour
qu'il déclare aussi le lancement de la
production
monsieur le président alberto fernandez
monsieur poutine
merci pour votre invitation à participer
ce forum de saint pétersbourg
en effet l'argentine était le premier
pays d'amérique du sud à avoir lancé la
production de et du spic v et le
deuxième au monde
et bien entendu ce n'est pas suffisant
il faut continuer cette lutte nous avons
l'intention d'utiliser largement le
vaccin produit par le
laboratoire d'amalia et tout cela est dû
à la coopération menée avec la recherche
russe la russie tape et ya fait des
efforts énormes non seulement pour
proposer de nouvelles de nouveaux modes
d'énergie mais aussi des recherches qui
a mené des recherches scientifiques
poussées dans le domaine pharmaceutique
et qui a fait beaucoup pour notre monde
notre métier avec la russie fêter ses
trente 130 ans et pendant cette période
nous sommes devenus des pays partenaires
et nous devons continuer à chercher à
nous développer le plus possible et à
renforcer cette coopération
curieusement cette pandémie a été une
occasion de rapprocher encore entre
d'assurer ce rapprochement entre la
russie et l'argentine au niveau des
gouvernements et pendant tant d'années
nous n'avions jamais une occasion
pareille je me souviens de la première
réunion que nous avons organisée dans le
cadre du g20
j'avais dit que le monde pourrait avoir
accès à un vaccin ce qui nous donnera
une nouvelle impulsion un nouveau coup
de pouce pour non seulement pour nous
mais aussi pour les autres pays en
développement pour participer à cette au
développement de cette formule du vaccin
et 7
c'est aussi très dynamique pour notre
pour notre production industrielle et ça
c'était une opportunité formidable pas
seulement pour notre pays mais pour
d'autres pays et des pays qui sont
beaucoup plus pauvres et cela est un
honneur pour nous de participer à la
diffusion de ce vaccin et je sais bien
que je ne suis pas le seul à partager
cet avis donc je note que en travaillant
avec le laboratoire gamme alliant nous
avons aussi la possibilité de travailler
au plus haut niveau de la coopération
scientifique et ça c'est le fruit direct
de l'activité du fonds du centre russe
des investissements directs et la
plupart la majorité des argentins le
savent très bien
ils savent qui a cette possibilité de
procéder à la vaccination
je suis très heureux de le noter et je
vous remercie sincèrement le
gouvernement argentin et moi en tant que
président nouveau président nous vous
remercions monsieur le président poutine
nous vous en sommes sincèrement
reconnaissants on dit les airs c'est
dans le besoin qu'on reconnaît ses amis
et bien voilà ici on en a une
illustration et temps le gouvernement
russe que le centre russe des
investissements directs que le
laboratoire
d'amalia vous avez été travaillé
ensemble et vous avez vous avez bien
travaillé avec lui et je sais que pour
nous la situation n'est pas perdu tant
qu'on a des alliés comme vous est donc
aujourd'hui concrètement nous lance nous
lançons la production de spoutnik vais
en argentine
et si cela vous convient
je pense que je pourrais revenir de
moscou chez moi en sachant qu'il y aura
d'autres initiatives qui pourraient être
proposées sur le plan de la coopération
riche et et sur le plan du vaccin aussi
peut-être avec leur hugo aussi nous
avons transmis aussi votre vaccin en
bolivie et nous espérons que de telle
façon que les pays vont se rapprocher
d'autres pays tels que le mexique et
d'autres pays d'amérique du sud et je
suis persuadé que le vaccin de
l'institut gamal ya sera accessible pour
l'ensemble du continent sud américain
je vous en remercie je vous remercie
d'avoir pris cette énorme responsabilité
je vous laisse et je vous serre la main
chaleureusement
je vous dis au revoir je vous laisse pas
je vous dis au revoir et merci encore
monsieur le président poutine pour ce
que vous avez fait pour nous
maintenant je dans la parole au
président du groupe de la bretonnerie
demande en chine pour lancer la
production industrielle du ce petit cul
et à l'argentine
merci merci beaucoup
car il bonsoir monsieur le président je
tiens à vous remercier le fonds russe
d'investissements directs et la russie
pour cette possibilité pour cette
occasion à cette pandémie
notre coopération permet de mettre fin
aux coronavirus ici d'un autre
laboratoire grâce à votre soutien nous
allons profiter de cette unique occasion
qui a été créée grâce à cette
coopération
la coopération qui consiste à produire
le vaccin ce foot nick v en argentine le
vaccin ce petit cube est le premier
vaccin en argentine l'argentine est le
premier vaccin d'amérique latine qui a
commencé la vaccination décembre à 2020
il y a presque six mois que le premier
lot de vaccin a été transféré en
argentine et maintenant nous sommes
prêts à lancer la fabrication du vaccin
ici à l'argentine je suis reconnaissant
aux fonds russe d'investissements
directs à je suis ravi de voir cette
unique occasion de lancer la fabrication
du vaccin qui a été à élaborer à part le
centre gamaleya
d'ici la fin de l'année 2020 nous
espérons de produire 100 millions 1,2
par an sera doit renforcer la production
industrielle en chine c'est un résultat
de travail en temps ce travail
scientifique travail de nos experts qui
ont permis de lancer la fabrication de
ce vaccin dans notre pays
aujourd'hui la construction de l'usiné
de pointe est en cours et dès que cette
usine sera construite nous allons
produire 500 millions d'euros par an
j'espère que vous monsieur le président
un jour pour y ait peu notre rêve
visitez notre régime à tout cela aurait
été impossible sans le soutien du
gouvernement de notre pays ainsi que du
fleurissement direct nous sommes prêts à
jouer un rôle décisif dans la lutte
contre la pandémie
je tiens à vous inviter invité tous ceux
qui sont présents ici aujourd'hui à
venir regarder le lancement de s'étudier
à l'argentine un monsieur le président
je vous demande d'autoriser le lancement
de l' usine
merci c'est très important c'est
effectivement le premier lancement de la
fabrication du switch-over amérique
latine et je tiens à remercier le
collègue serbe collègues à d'argentine a
donné la parole à nos collègues indiens
le pdg de la société et à ramer sur
heidi à vous la parole
je vous remercie
excellence monsieur poutine président de
la fédération aussi monsieur dmitriev
directeur du centre russe des
investissements directs chers collègues
bonsoir à tous pour moi c'est la
possibilité d'avoir cette fierté de
représentant la société hétéros qui a
donc cette possibilité devant monsieur
poutine de se présenter nous avons nous
travaillons depuis longtemps dans la
production de médicaments en inde
notamment de médicaments génériques et
d'autre
dix médicaments destinés à différentes
thérapies
cela nous permet de réduire les dépenses
de production de médicaments et nous
fournissons à peu près 40% des produits
antiviraux et ça fait assez longtemps
que nous travaillons avec la russie nous
avons particulier créé un site à moscou
à hauteur de 50 millions de dollars il y
a dix ans de grâce au merveilleux climat
d'affaires en russie
cette contribution cette coopération se
poursuit donc nous avons lutté ensemble
contre les vagues d'infection en inde
et toutes ces menaces pour notre
population
dès le début de la pandémie de kobe de
19 nous avons travaillé activement pour
développer cette coopération est avec le
fonds russe d'investissements directs
nous avons lancé plusieurs projets et
notamment des projets destinés à sauver
la vie de la population et remerciements
au centre russe des investissements
directs pour
d'avoir contribué à olemps mans de la
production jusqu aux tigres et en inde
d'autre part nous devons nous voulons
adapter cette production à notre
population c'est-à-dire pouvoir produire
200 millions de vaccins les parents et
nous exprimons notre gratitude au
président russe vladimir poutine qui
dans ses excellents rapports avec notre
pays monsieur n'à rôdera narendra modi
notre premier ministre a pu noter
récemment le rôle majeur de la russie
dans cette étape important et je pense
que dans cette crise qui est la plus
grande depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale cela permet de travailler
ensemble sur 7 pour la vox vaccination
je vous remercie de l'honneur qui m'a
été fait d'intervenir devant vous
[Musique]